we've got dried Butler and angela
bassett joining us on the show movie
stars on this set from London has fallen
where the guests damn car oh who cares
hey Dan Tiffany where the heck are you
they're not on the set of movie
threesome they're here at the hotel
where are you here gerard wants to talk
to you hey Tiffany
hey Tiffany hey Jerry Bullard and Angela
bicep II you just just worry about me
right now how are you been good it's
been so long by the way I do believe
Dyna engineered this whole thing so that
he could get us alone wouldn't worry
about it though Gerard you're pretty
buff like I think you could take him
yeah I'm I'm pretty yeah you like it I'm
sorry I don't trust this guy really good
clapping give it up for or Butler
clapping what's the deal with the second
well we couldn't bring in the real set
so I went to Kinko's and I printed what
I think is a pretty legit backup
Galileans Spartan helmet you like that
do you just like wear a Spartan helmet
around the house like that all the time
oh that's a that's like today gladiator
helmet yeah a little pistol brought it
on the show let's talk about the movie I
really enjoyed this it's way bigger than
the first one I mean the first one the
White House is attacked this time it's a
citywide attack on London was this a
more challenging film than the first one
yeah because it was citywide I mean it
was just a way bigger canvas we had to
make it in London and then rebuild a lot
of London and Bulgaria and shoot it
there as well and I was glad to get out
of the conference room yeah you prefer
being part of like the car crashes and
the helicopter scenes I go back and
forth he was like the best action star
of the lot because she always we
finished tanks and you'd be like oh I'm
in it let's keep going can you walk me
through that helicopter scene that was
the most like gut-wrenching scene
the whole movie whirling I don't want to
spoil too much but like we see it on the
trailer where the helicopters going down
tell me it actually this was a stunt we
crashed the helicopter and we had to hit
the side of a building they fired a
Stinger missile yep which hit the side
of the helicopter and we just had to
make sure that we were in the right part
of the hill right right the pilot had to
as the helicopter cut in half make sure
that we hit the side of the building and
then landed in a way that we could
survive the crash well let me ask you I
have always wanted the butler abs are
there any secrets on how to get those a
3d printing that's not real there it's
just a lot easier than you think sadly
that's a lot it's a lot of hard work
like when I when I did 300 I was
training six hours a day before the
movie started and then all the way
through the movie and you go out on a
crazy diet great while you're doing it
but then the second you stop the movie
yeah ice cream yeah you know again they
I think I'm working for Starbucks to do
a lemon the lemon cake you're gonna get
a million dollars from Starbucks they
better you both can't help but be
extremely badass in this film you're
both like equally badass do you have any
tips on how I could be a better badass
you look at me like oh it's not adorable
like this kid could be a badass with
work I can get that I would say
everything that you are right now yeah
you change everything then you're on
your way okay you guys exactly that's
badass I want to beating women when I
was driving at Kinkos right did you
bother you could learn from I don't even
think he really went to Kinko's let's be
honest I did not I want to move on to a
game the whisper game presidential
edition you guys can't be worried
bones you can't hear anything and I'm
gonna whisper some presidents names I'm
not from yet so I made my heaven make
struggles that I am from here what am i
struggle okay then we'll probably cut
this thing first president George
Washington the first point okay number
two next president eisenhower no John he
said John John Adam that is yes we're
techniques over there
and it was that it was that was Richard
Nixon Robert levy yes you got it
I'm Grover Cleveland you know I've never
even heard of all she was a president
did I win no not at all not at all
Angela you may have just had the first
ever whisper game sweep where you want
everyone so for that you get a Fandango
gift cards I'm gonna give you a Fandango
gift cards so thank you guys so much for
coming thank you for losing gracefully
thank you for being awesome guy from
stars of London has fallen
I did an interview with Tiffany and
Bulgaria didn't I that's right that's
right yeah
can I see that interview cut to that
sure let's
we are on the set of London has fallen
and where there's action well there's
visual effects and stunts a lot of them
I'm just from working with Jerry on this
one if you had to pick a head of your
Secret Service would you pick him we're
in Bulgaria who were actually controlled
in London take care of the bad guys
things up what's it like getting the
team back together
I've actually never done a sequence or
any of my movies that's not true that is
untrue okay
I've actually never done a sequel before
so it's really nice to actually be able
to say to somebody no how are you but
hey have you been since yes that's a
very safe shot that we were doing
because it's now a mortar filled with
soft materials so you can stand right in
front of that there's another problem
what do we have here cuz this rig looks
pretty heavy-duty it is because it has
to support the whole weight of the
vehicle when it tips up on end so this
end attaches to a large steel structure
that's attached to the road and in the
front of the vehicle
is an explosive camera well the one
thing that Dan can't steal from us is
the weekly that is true my spirits will
be lifted because my win streak
continues you can't beat me my least
favorite show we've ever done oh it's so
great because last week we bet on Eddie
the Eagle
I bet 9 million you made the wrong
decision of going over and going 925 to
jack the price was wrong for you and the
actual numbers work which means this
week's loser should comes from youtube
user ridicule who says loser should call
their parents and tell them one thing
they did behind their backs well I'm
gonna call my dad because my dad is a
big fan of movie threesome hey daddy
I lost the weekly wager again yeah so
this week I have to call you to tell you
something I did behind your back when I
remember when my chores were to empty
the cat litter box and like take the
poop out garbage cans in the backyard
yeah I remember when you thought
something died at the garage cause it
smelled so bad in the summer yeah why is
the throw the cat poop behind the fridge
I love you bye mr. Smith London has
fallen it's time to bet on that one I
already talked about you that's I am
gonna go first and for me I am going to
bet and say 25 million along this pond
what is your wrong back 26 million okay
Jerry
don't let me down to the box office
buddy it has nothing us nothing to do
with him it as it has everything to do
with the fact that I am perfect loser
should what do you do you hashtag it you
put it in the YouTube comments and you
suggest what the hell she's gonna do for
the rest of the year because she can't
beat me
gonna win no I'm gonna win sure how many
times have you told yourself that this
is all right so first I just have to say
a huge sorry to Gerard Butler and Angela
Bassett that we didn't get to interview
them I guess yeah sorry guys you missed
out on the a-team you got the B team
make sure that right now subscribe right
over there and check out past episodes
right here download the Fandango movie
clips app on your smartphone join us
every week here on movie three oh you're
such a jerk